je suis assise avec tout le monde pour
connaître leur choix leur préférence
puis essayer de trouver quel était le
meilleur le meilleur dossier pour eux au
bout du compte dans ce cas-ci on n'a pas
été capable de
s'entendre là-dessus puis il y avait pas
de dossier finalement on voit bien que
ça a été trop loin je pense que il faut
le reconnaître puis dire ben on envoie
un message d'une main tendue moi j'ai
une main tendue à Marie-Claude depuis
vendredi je parle je souhaite ensuite
que en ce qui réintègre ces fonctions de
députés
au lendemain de cette main tendue par la
chef du Parti libéral Dominique Anglade
la députée de Vaudreuil Marie-Claude
Nikos a pris sa décision elle ne
souhaite pas réintégrer le caucus
libéral pourquoi tombe-t-elle le dos au
parti qu'elle représente depuis 2014
elle brise le silence pour la première
fois depuis son expulsion jeudi dernier
bonsoir madame Nicole merci accordé cet
entretien à 24 60 alors est-ce que ça a
été j'imagine une décision difficile
pour vous de prendre cette décision de
ne pas réintégrer le cocus la décision
la plus difficile de ma carrière
politique j'aurais presque de ma vie
parce que c'est ma famille c'est ma
famille politique je l'ai tournée
pendant
de tout sens du côté puis je me disais
que c'était impossible de réintégrer le
focus dans les présentes conditions sans
aucune excuse de la part de personnes
surtout de la chef même si elle dit que
c'est pressé à l'opinion précipiter j'ai
jamais eu d'excuses dans les six
derniers jours donc quand j'ai envoyé le
courriel
focus libéral pesé sur le envoyer
ça a été pour moi mon coeur s'est mis à
saigner puis je m'aime encore très
émotif quand est-ce que je comprends que
si Madame Anglade vous avez offert des
excuses vous auriez réintégrer le caucus
ça a été ma première question quand j'ai
rencontré Dominique hier je lui ai dit
Dominique ça fait 5 jours j'ai toujours
pas d'excuses est-ce que tu comptes
t'excuser j'ai jamais eu de réponse et à
ce moment-là on est passé quelles sont
tes propositions parce que la main
tendue j'entendais l'introduction le la
main tendue on s'entend que c'est pas
une vraiement étendue là c'est un
opération de relation publique de
communication pour bien parents et tout
donc il est pas question même si elle
vous avait offert des excuses vous
seriez peut-être pas retourner dans le
coquelus libéral je vous suis bien je
comprends bien parfait il fallait offrir
des excuses dans les dans les délais qui
ont suivi l'expulsion parce que c'est
une expulsion vraiment cavalière mais
cavalière qui était
injustifié sur toute la ligne avec des
conséquences énormes des conséquences
pour les membres de mon équipe ma
famille mais pas ma mère ma mère cinq
jours quatre heures il y a des
conséquences partout mais les
conséquences sur la grande famille
libérale c'est incroyable puis je pense
même au monde présentement les nouveaux
élus au caucus au caucus libéral qui
sont dynamiques fougueux qui ont envie
de travailler qui veulent être sur le
terrain c'est une fraction
inutile présentement causée de toutes
parts par la décision et que vous voulez
pas nourrir vous dites à votre Messie
aujourd'hui que vous voulez pas comment
dire offrir une bouée de sauvetage à la
chef Dominique Anglade en acceptant
cette main tendue vous voulez pas la
sauver d'elle-même si j'interprète là
mais en fait je suis profondément blessé
par qu'est-ce qui est arrivé il y a
toujours pas eu d'excuse et c'est pas
vrai que je vais être la bouée de
sauvetage de décision précipiter la
prochaine fois qu'on prenne le temps
qu'on réfléchisse c'est ce que j'ai fait
dans les six derniers jours ma décision
d'aujourd'hui
c'est pas facile elle était pas évidente
mais j'avais pas j'avais j'avais pas
d'autre choix
parce que la façon ça s'est passé ce
qu'on apprend dans votre missive
aujourd'hui bon on sait que Madame
anglaise vous souhaitiez la
vice-président de l'Assemblée nationale
vous aviez mis le transport le dossier
du transport comme 4e choix et c'est
celui que Madame Morgane vous a offert
que vous avez refusé mais ce qu'on
apprend dans votre missif c'est que
finalement vous vous êtes entendus sur
le fait que vous n'ayez pas vous
n'auriez pas finalement de
responsabilité particulière il n'y a pas
de lien avec la troisième vice-président
de l'Assemblée nationale c'était mon
premier choix puis ça j'avais fait
j'avais fait falloir à Dominique que
l'ancienneté et l'expérience devait
primer que je suis avocat que j'étais
mince préférée que je suis capable de
trancher j'ai vendu ma salade à
Dominique et on en a pas tenu compte
elle n'en a pas tenu compte vous a
préféré Franz Benjamin pour d'autres
considérations sans doute en tout cas
qui était plus junior que vous à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est clair mais
ce que je comprends c'est que même en
dépit du fait que vous ayez refusé ce
qu'elle vous offrait une ciment le
transport aussi du transport vous êtes
quand même entendu pour que vous restiez
bon mais vous aurez pas de
responsabilité particulière j'ai bien
compris ça tout à fait j'ai jamais
menacé de claquer la porte quand
Dominique m'a appelé le mardi à 18h30 je
savais bien que tous les autres membres
que ça va être déjà leur fonction
parlementaire quand on m'a dit c'est ton
quatrième choix ou rien
j'ai réfléchi moi je pensais qu'on était
là pour négocier sincèrement on a un
cabinet fantôme on est là on a toujours
négocié je l'ai vécu je l'ai vécu avec
d'autres chefs interimaires on a
toujours négocié nos fonds ça fait que
moi je m'attendais à négocier on m'a dit
c'est ça ou rien puis je l'ai dit c'est
rien puis c'était correct c'était
entendu comme ça c'était rien mais il y
avait pas de il y avait pas j'ai pas
fait de menace on a convenu c'était rien
mais le lendemain tout est viré tout
achat viré on m'a dit on peut pas sortir
d'un comité avec rien ça prend des
fonctions parlementaires et je vois pas
je vois pas c'est pas la première fois
là que une députée a pas de fonction
parlementaire autour de la table au
contraire Dominique a déjà retiré des
dossiers à Pierre Arquin à Gaetan
barrette puis ma collaboration était là
si on m'envoie dans les commissions
avec Dominique donc elle vous tend la
main elle vous offre pas d'excuses vous
restez avez-vous dit à plusieurs
reprises profondément libérales c'est un
parti auquel vous êtes attaché mais vous
jugez
non Dominique malheureusement elle a pu
elle a essayé puis on était là derrière
elle on l'a accompagné pour essayer de
mais c'est la pire des Fêtes historiques
du Parti libéral le client apprend
clairement pas les bonnes décisions elle
est vraiment mal conseillée aussi le
Dominique Dominique n'a plus le plus le
leadership pour être à la tête du parti
Québec alors madame Mesco on vous verra
quand même dans les couloirs de
l'Assemblée nationale et CG comme
indépendantes pour représenter fièrement
les citoyens du compter de votre œil
merci beaucoup merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]